shadow foreign secretary david lami is
with us hello to you mr lammy thank you
for joining us on the program um what's
your view we have heard the number of
people that are in hospital at the
moment nevertheless do you think that
the government are being suitably
cautious
look i think this is a national
emergency it's all shoulders to the
wheel to ensure that the country
is boosted and it's right of course that
people wear their masks
uh in public the people stay at home um
if they can and we as the opposition
want to support the national effort in
this time to reduce the risks
to the population this this mutation is
serious and we have to be cautious and
the government are right i think in
their approach at this stage
is it right that the prime minister
addresses the nation um
on a sunday evening and people are
rightfully um
quite anxious when something like that
happens is that what we're looking for
well i don't want to play politics with
the
how this is done i know that there were
certainly some journalists who would
have liked been able to put
questions to the prime minister but i
think the message
that the country should go out and
ensure that they are boosted that they
should make an appointment now
to get boosted before the end of the
month is the correct message
and it's certainly my responsibility and
the labour party's responsibility to
back that call and to do all we can to
ensure that we get the message out in
our channels
and with the media that's available to
us
okay um
should boris johnson resign
well look the truth is that boris
johnson has lost a lot of credibility uh
in the last few weeks there are many
questions facing his performance this
quiz that we heard about
at the weekend and of course the parties
but boris johnson has an 80 c majority
so k that really in the end is a
question
to conservative back benches uh i don't
want to be in the business of gesture
policies because it's not something that
the british labor party can deliver
that's the truth of it we can't
there are huge problems with boris
johnson he's the worst prime minister to
have at this time but equally there's no
point in me sort of gesturing when in
the end the nature of our democracy that
the parliamentary majority has means
that we can't deliver that
but your leader said yesterday it looks
like boris johnson was breaking the law
so what next thing
he certainly needs to come to parliament
today
to explain what happened i mean he's not
ann robinson he was conducting a quiz at
the time you should not have been
socially mixing uh in
london he's flanked by others there's no
social distancing you weren't
beyond
and the photograph of what we're hearing
about this quiz and drinks and things
that were had of course suggest that
this was a
flagrant breach of the rules but he's
now got to come to parliament and
explain himself
but looking at this picture i mean you
know it's difficult to tell there could
well be a metre apart there are only
three of them in the picture i mean
that's hardly a hanging offense is it
could should
the point is that boris johnson is the
public lead chief
for our country he's the person who has
to set the example he's the person in
the end who makes the ultimate call on
the rules that we all had to abide by
and with in these very serious times
where it may be
that we come back to the public and ask
for further restrictions
look it's hugely important that they
believe that the prime minister and
those that work with him are taking this
seriously for all of those reasons he
has to explain himself uh in the house
and to the country um let's talk about
the by-election on thursday as a result
of owen patterson um stepping down
labour i think i'm right in saying that
you were second last time albeit a long
way behind why are you not being touted
by the bookies as being able to win the
seat this time they're going with the
lib dems they said the lib dems will win
i i don't think this is a seat that
labour have
ever held it's a
significant majority this is uh
traditionally conservative seat
we are doing all that we can knocking on
doors getting our message across we'll
see what the result is uh on thursday
but i don't think that
on the arithmetic people are suggesting
that this is a seat that we should
easily hold
um no but if you know looking at how
well you're doing in the polls at the
moment and it looks but nevertheless it
looks as though the bookies are saying
the lib dems will win that's going to
give you guys a bloody nose as well
isn't it
let's wait and see what happens on
thursday um
you know in the end uh
you know there's electioneering going on
people have not yet gone to the polls uh
clearly
um
they will have seen the chaos that the
government's in over the last few weeks
and they will have heard the message
coming from the british labour party so
let's wait and see
yeah but if the libertarians win it's
not good for either of the main parties
is it
oh i'm not gonna i'm not gonna call the
results of the of the election but uh
you know i i'd i'd be surprised if the
nintendos uh took the seat but let's see
well
as i said to the uh health sector
earlier on you never see a poor bookie
do you let's talk about what's happening
as far as russia is concerned foreign
ministers of g7 meeting in liverpool
yesterday warning russia of massive
consequences if it invades ukraine given
uh your brief um how do we start to
de-escalate what's going on there
well look i think that the meeting
between biden and putin was very serious
and i was in washington last week uh
discussing this with colleagues um uh in
the us
um this is a very worrying situation and
uh putin needs to step back
uh nato is
absolutely unifying there will be severe
consequences uh if there is any breach
you know ukraine is an autonomous
independent democratic country um it is
for them to determine their future
uh putin must now step back and know
that nato is absolutely unified the
european union is unified in the
approach that we will take
before i let you go did you see the race
yesterday was lewis robbed
i felt sorry for lewis hamilton i've got
to tell you um i don't know if he was
robbed it certainly looked a bit chaotic
and confused towards the end but he'll
live to fight another day i'm sure
i agree it's good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed mr lammy thank you
thank you